I'm waiting to talk to a man who was the
public face of the German car industry
which employs hundreds of thousands of
people
what does Matthias Whisman think about
German trade ties with the United States
the head of Germany's Automotive
Industry Association has just 15 minutes
for me he's much sought after right now
protectionism is back in fashion what
does that mean for the German car
industry raising artificial barriers to
protect yourself against competition
might offer a short-term advantage but
in the mid to long term your own
economy's ability to compete will suffer
because it doesn't have the benefits of
facing up to competitors I don't think
protectionism is a wise long-term
strategy and certainly not for the
United States I'll see her need for the
fighting style but US president Donald
Trump says there are too many German
cars on America's roads and too few
American cars on German roads how many
it's gotta be a two-way street I want to
be fair there's gotta be a two-way
street but the facts show another
picture in 2016 Volkswagen BMW and
Mercedes at a US market share of 7.6%
in the same year US car makers General
Motors and Ford cornered a European
market share of 13 and a half percent
the Americans have a much stronger
presence in Europe than German car
makers in the u.s. in no way do we have
the attitude that America is purely an
export market for us we have a strong
manufacturing presence there we stand
for hundreds of thousands of jobs we're
part of America's industrial base and I
think once everyone's understood that
then all the excitement will just die
down
[Music]
this is the Volkswagen plant in
Chattanooga Tennessee German car makers
employ 110,000 people in the US
including 77,000 in the supply chain
adding the dealerships and repair shops
linked to their brands the numbers rise
to several hundred thousand last year
eight hundred and fifty thousand units
rolled off German car makers production
lines in the u.s. forty-one percent of
them were sold on a domestic market
twenty five percent were exported to
Europe 25 percent to Asia Germany's car
makers are highly globalized let me put
a number to it twenty years ago we made
four million cars a year in Germany and
1 million around the world yet simulates
white toast in the year that just ended
2016 we made 5.7 million cars in Germany
but around the world
we made 10 million and production in
places like the US has profited
handsomely from that finding starting
start for field German car makers have
three plants in the US all of them
including BMWs have some of their parts
made in Mexico but recent noises from
the White House means that automotive
supplies from Mexico could be hit with a
35% import tax that will increase car
makers US production costs enormous Lee
so do you think a trade war is looming
on the horizon you know my opinion is
that it's better to calm people down
it's no good to head straight for
confrontation of confrontation
I think discussions are always
preferable mother's Matias Whisman hopes
Washington will appreciate the logic of
his arguments he believes it's only a
matter of time